my phone now rings on the
computer number of
different
going to go ahead and open up the
meeting welcome to the special committee
uh for the Department the division of
children youth and families uh would you
please stand and join me in the Pledge
of
Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you good morning couple of
housekeeping items uh if you are
testifying and you have written
testimony if you could please hand that
up to the clerk um before you start
speaking and if you wish to submit
written testimony online you may do so
by emailing the committee and we have
our own email address
even which I will give to
you I'll pull it up after and tell you
um I've also reached out to it and house
committee Services um and they're going
to help us make sure that you can submit
testimony online on the online
submission form right now you have to
put in a bill number so the the form
isn't working working for on our
committee web page so we're going to
work on fixing that and um that being
said if you have documents that contain
sensitive information um you're expected
to self- redact any information that you
might have court orders not to share or
um you know personal information that
you wouldn't want to become part of the
public
record our topic of today is due process
where did it come from what is it when
is it required are the different kinds
of it
uh what are the essential essential
elements of it so I see we have a number
of guests here who may inform us of
their understanding of due process and
members of the committee also have their
expertise uh to share on that and
um perhaps there are some stories from
people in the audience about their
experiences with due process as it
relates to
DCF and uh then afterward the committee
will have an opportunity for
discussion our committee researcher was
kind of enough to provide us with um
some
documents and uh so there were a lot of
them and that would have been a lot of
paper so if there's anything that you
all want printed for us to have here for
our discussion after specifically um we
can let Christina know if you want to
um we can just ask her and then we can
get those
printed
right
okay so think I will
start with calling the first
witness didn't even look through these
sorry so I think I'll go ahead and call
First witness is Joshua
peruse Madam chair any point of order
yes um pursuant to RSA
1414 which states any Senator or
representative while acting as a member
of a committee of the
legislature May administer an oath to
any person who may be examined before
such committee I would like to require
an oath of the witness and all Witnesses
testifying before this committee the
testimony we are taking is concerning
very serious subject matter and we must
ensure truthfulness they have been
various committees both ad hoc and
standing which Have Heard lots of
testimony relative to family law matters
and in many cases can go on and on and
take up lots of precious time and
sometimes it was later found out that
testimony was INF factual what we want
want to do is establish that this
process is eliciting factual information
so we can make the most informed
decisions based on the testimony we
receive um well I've looked up that that
RSA myself um and it is our I I'll allow
it the point taken it I think it's very
prudent representative Weber did you
have a point of order yes um it's it's
something that we normally do not do
and this is not a tribunal this is a
fact finding Mission and uh it's seems
to me that to require an oath um is way
outside of our normal um
procedure
and as one who assumes people standing
in front of us are going to be truthful
um uh I think it's I think it's frankly
kind of insulting to our Witnesses but I
also uh the point of this commission
committee is to discover issues with
DCF it is not to prepare the ground for
some kind of future
prosecution and so I think that the
administration of an oath is
um both unnecessary and insulting and I
would um
really prefer to get a ruling from the
speaker's office as to whether it's an
appropriate thing for us to be doing
because I've literally in 18 years never
seen it okay um I appreciate your
thoughts uh I I'm going to go forward
and permit the oath to be performed upon
the witness uh I'm going to object until
we have a go from the speaker's office
you
take actually I can comment yep go ahead
uh thank you madam chair
uh so a lot of people that testify in my
experience
um I run the perception that they were
wrong um there are often times when uh
their perception was
changed uh and they didn't go through
the right people uh the fact that people
are showing up here taking their time
out of their day to show up here I trust
um I do p onion to see where something
is may not be the reality but it's their
reality and I absolutely agree that it's
their reality uh so to put them under
oath I think would um you know would
harm that um okay because it you know if
we find out later that it wasn't the
fact but it's their perception and their
fact that may be problematic so um
before I hear your thoughts
representative I'm going to share my own
um I I think that it's good form to
expect truthfulness in our um
testimonies that we receive here and we
can't make any decisions if we're
receiving any information that is um
frivolous unnecessary or untruthful of
course um the uh you can't you
can't you can't verify that the
information that you're receiving is
truthful without an oath so this is such
a serious matter and I I understand it
hasn't been done but we do have the The
Authority in the statute in chapter one
of our state statutes that's something
that we have the right to
exercise um you know in our duties to
serve the people um so we don't have any
house rules against it and um I I think
it's very important that it's applied I
think it should be applied evenly and I
I would like to see it in all committee
hearings in the house um and I thank the
representative for for bringing that up
and I uh I'm I would like to to allow
these Witnesses or or i' would like to
ensure that all Witnesses in this
committee are under
oath go ahead I'd like to second that
motion uh because RSA 1414 States any
Senator or representative while acting
as a member of the committee of the
legisl May administer a note it's
already in the RSA I don't think we need
to go any further by checking with the
clerk that's in the
RSA do you call
me so the clerk has ruled that we can
administer an oath you are not required
to take it um but we can we can ask that
you
do go ahead thank you madam chairwoman
you know my the committee that um
representative long and I serve on has
the same in representative Panic we have
the same um you know level I think all
committees have the same level of of
importance I think one of the hardest
things for getting people to testify and
come testify is the great amount of
pressure that we have particularly even
abuse victims we're going to deal with
people here that have abuse and there's
gaslighting what their truth is we
really should just be open to hearing
it's up to us to discern what we take
from that particular testimony but I
actually think it will limit free the
freedom to talk and testimony I think
it's an unnecessary and I do think that
it's
um insulting to do that so I I do not
think that we should go that
route representative
Weber I think the last thing that I
would say on the subject is that first
off um we all hope and expect that the
truth will be stated here people who are
not truthful are not necessarily going
to be deterred by an oath except to the
extent that they might be prosecuted
afterwards
and I just think that with the gravity
and the emotionalism that comes with
these most deeply personal
proceedings um as as others have said um
one's emotions are in Tangled and I
think it's very unwise but I can also
count votes so um thank you for letting
me say
that representative long thank you madam
chair uh will representatives and
Senators be taking olds also if they're
testifying anyone who is testifying I I
should I should expect I think that it
should be applied evenly to anyone
before the committee and we have already
had one person testify without taking a
oath correct yeah so it's beginning now
every witness will uh will have an oath
sworn all right sir would you
representative Panic would you um
perform the oath on the witness do you
have I can do it all right sir if you
would stand and raise your right
hand do you swear that the testimony
that you are about to provide is the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes I do thank
you does it not have to be
either under God or but under the pains
and penalties of perjury if they're
swearing an oath from what I have read
uh there's no particular form as long as
it's understood that it's an oath and
that the one that I just gave is almost
word for word the one that's given in
federal courts
okay all
right
so see sorry I lost your card already
did you take it okay J Mr
peruse um Franklin New Hampshire okay do
you know how long you're going to need
for your testimony
today okay all right thank you for being
here and go
ahead okay state your name for the
record my name is Joshua peruse Madame
chairwoman members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to share my
testimony
today a little bit of background on
myself in 2014 I was divorced uh three
kids at the time and in in the process
of that divorce proceeding I was
homeless and so at the time I agreed to
a parenting plan that allowed me that
allowed her to have custody of the the
kids where I get uh parenting time as
agreed by both
parties and that worked well for a while
until it was untenable um the other
party would not work with me as well as
I was hoping and so
in May of 2023 I filed a motion in court
uh to try and get that amended after
getting back on my feet um I worked
through getting a part and now I'm a
homeowner and so I'm I'm in a much
better position now to be able to be a
parent for my
children um so
in I have to double check May 3rd of
2023 I filed a motion in court towards
that
end
and on the 5th the other party was
served by the
sheriff and on the 8th a complaint was
filed with
DCF
uh against me that I had harmed one of
our
children and in on the 18th 10 days
later I was
informed that there was a dcyf and
detective investigation occurring uh
regarding an incident that was
claimed a safety plan was issued at that
time regarding one of the
children
and um I see
here appreciate you letting me refer my
notes just to make sure that I am
factual um there was some contact
between Me Myself and the
DCF uh
cpsw uh working on this and I did self
redact so if you need the documents I
can provide them um and the first safety
plan stated during investigation the
report of concern of physical abuse
exposing the child to DV and putting
hands on and non-negotiable using any
form of physical discipline with the
child or any of the
children uh that was the first safety
plan regarding one child and without my
knowledge or permission that was uh the
other children were
added
um and I was I was working with an
attorney when we had filed the petition
in court so my attorney was working with
me and giving me some advice on this as
well it was reasonable to agree to it at
the
time
and um I was
informed when I was first called by the
dcyf
cpsw it was apparent that she did not
like
me
um
it it came across very easily to
understand that she believed I was
guilty of
what they were
claiming and that was from the from the
outset 10 days after the case was opened
with
DCF and when I was first
notified and I was informed that at that
time on that phone call that I would
have a home visit soon as soon as I had
talked to the
detective regarding the case in a
criminal matter though same same claimed
incident I had to talk to the detective
and then she would talk to me was the
claim and then it continued where I was
trying to get the home visit and it was
delayed and delayed and delayed um to
the point
where I was
told in uh let's see here as I mentioned
to you on the phone our visit
appointments have been tentative on the
investigation process due to the
investigation still pending with the
detective will need to reschedule
tomorrow's visit until the detective is
complete which was different than what
I'd been told on the
phone so her claim was that the
detective's office had to complete their
investigation before they would even
agree to a home visit with
me and then uh further
uh safety plans were enacted and it was
all verbal on my part uh where she would
call me and I would verbally agree to
the safety plan um and the second one
began with all the children were
included where they uh would not where
they would stay with their mother um but
there was no notification that I could
not have any contact with any of them uh
the mother
P the mother restricted my
contact to the point where I
had no contact at all for a month and a
half with my
children um and after this went on for a
while on June 13th I sent an email
stating that I revoked my agreement to
the safety plan that res restricts my
contact and parenting time with the
children I still had not yet had the
home visit on June
13th
and at that time I was H the response on
the same day was that they would have
their attorney contact
mine
and at that time we had informed them
that there were witnesses to the time
period where they claimed that an
incident happened and at that moment
still June nobody had talked to any of
those Witnesses the home visit had not
been
completed um I had requested records
requests uh through DCF trying to get
records showing anything that I could so
that I could understand what even the
allegations were against
me uh the cpsw did not notate any of
that to
me and then
on June
22nd on my my behalf uh my attorney sent
an a
letter stating that I had not seen spent
any time with or had any sort of contact
with my children in over a month and a
half
um despite my recent rejection of the
safety plan the children's mother has
taken the position that the safety plan
remains in effect and stands for the
proposition that I must have absolutely
no contact with the
children at that time he had spoken with
law enforcement and he stated that the
detective had told us from the uh police
office investigating that they did not
advise DCF of any position against
parent or child contact they further
stated that they communicated to DCF
that it does not need to wait for for
the police department to further its own
investigation DCF had full permission to
do the home
visit um and yet they were still not
doing it
sorry um then we received a response on
July 3 my attorney sent the the letter
on June 22nd we got a response on July
3D I still had not had any time with the
kids um that they
understood
that
I no longer agree to the safety plan
it's a voluntary safety plan it's no
longer in effect they agreed to that at
that time they had asked the mother to
be protective of the
children
um and that was on June July 3 where I
received
that and the timeline from there becomes
interesting
because on July
14th was my arrest uh regarding the
incident and I was released on PR
Bill and then I received a notice of no
complaint on September 12th uh the da
was not going to further the um in
court two days later I received the
notice of finding from
DCF or so the notice of no complaint was
filed by the
da on
September 12th two days later on
September 14th DCF filed their letter of
finding they found against me but I had
not been
offered sorry I did not mention when the
home visit happen actually did
happen
um
sorry okay the DCF home visit happened
on August
25th we presented our
evidence and we spoke with the dcyf cpsw
for a good while probably about two
hours upon receiving the records from
DCF about this that home visit and
absolutely none of the evidence that we
presented was even included in the
report
and the final letter of finding from
DCF
like I said it is self redacted so I
will not speak
anything um that should not be
redacted two children were interviewed
during the process of their
investigation they both stated that I
did perform this allegation uh the
alleged
incident
no other investigation was notated on
the letter of
finding on on July 18th I turned myself
in for the charges brought against me by
the police department the charge of
second degree assault but again I
received a letter of no uh notice of no
complaint but it states that based on
the forging that child that is an abused
child and I am the person responsible
for that abuse according to their
finding DCF has determined that I Joshua
peruse are the individual responsible
for the abuse described above as a
result of this finding my name has been
permanently added to the DCF central
registry I was not taken before a
hearing the only contact that I had with
DCF during this entire invest
investigation was with the
cpsw minor contact with her
supervisor and my attorney talking with
their
attorney at no time did I sit before a
panel or any grouping of individuals
where I was able to actually present
evidence and to be included in the final
report or for
consideration and yet they state that on
the preponderance of evidence I am
guilty
that was their
wording preponderance of
evidence sorry I forgot to read that but
that is in the
finding and that is based on the
testimony of two minor
children not the four adults that were
also
there which I had given them names phone
numbers contact information for each of
them and they were all willing to
testify on my
on the behalf of the
children I open myself for questions if
you have any thank you and um thank you
for being here and and I understand that
this is painful and details are hard to
get through sometimes so we we get that
and we're very patient and you did a
great job thank you is are there any
questions from the committee
representative
long thank you madam chairwoman uh thank
you for your story this is exactly what
we're looking at and you articulated it
well
um was was there any police
finding the
police presented the case to the DA and
the da rejected it there was no finding
by the police I did not stand in court
before a judge uh regarding the criminal
matter and a follow up I made follow up
um
the uh was there a uh Child Advocacy
Center interview yes with two of the
children but there were there were three
other children present that day there
were no
CAC uh interviews regarding
them so my understanding as a complaint
was on one child correct dcyf included
the other two child
children uh the one child and the Tes of
one other child okay so so they were
involved to and CAC interviewed one of
the children the child in question and
one other child that was the only CAC
interview that I was made aware of well
you were your attorney present negative
we were not informed of it until after
the fact okay very good thank you
representative
Kofa thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you for your testimony and for
taking my question so you described the
first conversation with the
cpsw and made the statement and I think
I have this right it came across that
she believed I was guilty correct can so
that's a subjective um Absol judgment
about that call can you offer some sort
of factual context to help us understand
what was said uh by whom and just a
little more background on that
conversation so that we can understand
it reasonable request I appreciate the
opportunity when she called me
um the the tone was forceful and
honestly
argumentative uh she presented
herself introduced
herself
and
stated that when this incident
happened and furthered and followed
questions behind that assuming that the
incident had
happened and the the tone of voice
was again
forceful which to a point I understand
um as a
female talking to a male who has been
accused of certain things there is a
certain tone that must be necessary
but sorry forgive me
um it
was trying to think I didn't write notes
about this particular phone call so bear
with me I
please
um there was an accusation at the the
beginning at during the phone call that
I had done it uh it
was that we're talking about the phone
call yeah okay oh wife's helping me
out
um
the sorry I I would say that probably if
you don't remember the specifics don't
re for him too much but I we understand
the idea that you felt it that way sorry
I
shouldn't Weber oh you have a followup
Jim sorry I do thank you so I guess I
just want to clarify um it sounds like
you're saying that she referred to the
accusations as fact as as factual yes
not as accusations am I accurate in
describing what I heard from you yes you
are thank you representative
Weber
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here today and sharing your story
which I can't imagine could be easy in
any way uh I you alluded to this but I
just want to clarify and be sure I have
this correct um there
was the criminal prosecution was
discontinued is that correct yes ma'am
it is and then there was no judicial
proceeding uh with respect to the abuse
and neglect complaint is that correct
that is correct so you never went to
court on that that is correct and then
your name was placed in a registry that
is correct and you didn't have any
chance to challenge that before it
happened before it happened no it is no
I did not have that opportunity okay was
was there an opportunity after it
happened the opportunity um along with
the letter of finding they did tell me
that I could appeal it okay uh however
with the proceedings going on with
family court and trying to gain some
type of parenting plan with the other
party uh to be able to spend time with
the kids I was advised by my Council to
not pursue an
appeal you're
welcome
representative thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you I'll Echo the
thank you for being here to testify we
know it's not easy especially with um
circumstances and involving children I
just wanted to clarify I into two
questions that's okay what was your
relationship up until the complaint
which was filed on May 8th what kind of
contact or relationship did you had with
the children up until then uh up until
that point every other weekend they
would spend with me okay uh as agreed by
the other party um sometimes it would
happen most of the times it would okay
and when um they thank you for answering
that when uh was the incident uh that
was alleged to have occurred what was
that date it was uh three days before it
was the Friday before
that uh so I can I have my calendar
here okay so it was the Friday before so
it was the 5ifth so the fifth and you
said that you had you filed paperwork on
the 3D correct correct uh uh paperwork
was filed on the 2 okay the the alleged
incident on the
5th and the DCF complaint was filed on
the eth okay thank you very
much any further questions from the
committee I have a question um what are
the consequences of having your name on
that registry
do you know I'll be perfectly honest I
do not know it was not explained to me
by the DCF uh cpsw okay and were you
ever able to have that finding
overturned afterward I had a limited
window within uh that I was told that I
had availability to appeal and that
window has long since expired but I
haven't I believe uh one year from the
date of finding that I am able to get
that
expunged which I will be seeking to do
okay thank
you oh representative W thank you madam
chair uh the current status that you
have three children uh are you able to
visit with any of those children Yes
actually um many things have gotten
positive um with the family court the
other party and I actually actually came
to an agreement where I have many
weekends with them now um they stay with
me from Friday evening through Monday
morning it used to be
only pick them up on Friday night and I
get them until Sunday night but now I
have even more time with them um we have
a far more organized parenting plan
where I actually share um legal
responsibility for them that's great and
that's all three children yes super
thank
you not seeing any further questions
thank you very much for taking the time
out of your day to come testify this is
very helpful thank
you we will go to the next
witness I will
[Music]
call Katrina
Hinrich exitor New
Hampshire and if you are going to speak
today I see there are more people in the
audience than I was going to say I see
you're passing out pin cards now make
sure you fill out a pin card thank
you
okay and if you wouldn't mind standing
and raising your right hand and to swear
an oath to truthfulness in your
testimony do you swear to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth in the testimony that you're about
to provide yeah thank
you you may
proceed so there are some handouts
coming to you I just wanted you to be
aware of
those
good morning
everybody Madam chair thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
today I am Katrina
Heinrich today I'm going to speak to you
from a place of experience little bit of
research background and organizational
compliance and financial industry for
me and while the education and
professional experiences has allowed me
to better understand the function and
issues of Family Court due process the
associated agencies there's nothing as
insightful as being in the New Hampshire
family court system for over a
decade this is my experience and my
conclusions DCF was involved very
quickly in my case and very quickly fell
off while they came to visit they
decided that there was no help they
could possibly offer Us in the abuse
that was
occurring I asked for resources none was
given you have to talk to the police you
have to do this no matter what Avenues I
took nothing was helping
me I felt as if dcyf was kind of putting
up a wall and they were so disinterested
in my
kids with that
said in a post- divorce
scenario I found myself in family court
for no stated
reasons but yet we were
there so over the decade that I
experienced this I can confident ly say
that my blind trust in the concept of
court and expectation that truth and
evidence would put an end to the post
divorce rivality and abuses was actually
in the end the very qualities I felt
they were looking for to protract the
case and it fostered
conflict and it also revealed a lot of
perjury and in one of your handouts
you'll see it says perjury in Family
Court of New Hampshire this was written
by a Manchester attorney named Shauna El
Brown She subtitled it the truth the
whole truth or well something like the
truth and if you'll refer to the first
page of it in the second paragraph and
the second
sentence it talks about due to the
nature of family court system potential
for perjury is great and if that's the
case as she goes on to to absolutely
solidify due process is being subverted
at every
angle every
institution further down she says
professional conduct rule 3.3 requires
us all to correct the
record instead the attorneys quit and
they never correct the record and that
happened in my case a
lot and later you'll hear me speak that
that we had over 15 attorneys in the
case over five judges over this
decade on the second page you'll notice
that she talks about perjury occurring
and the result and and and I'm bringing
this up because this is what I felt and
what I
experienced is that the offending party
being awarded for their conduct while
providing no relief at all
for me and my children the innocent
party and yet we incurred all the legal
expenses and the emotional dpress and
lack of effort
or as far as I could tell the court
interest in revealing the
truth so again due
process the reality that she writes is
the same thing I
experience the party who is willing to
lie under oath is oftentimes rewarded
while those who attempt to tell the
truth are
not this is beyond the norm to me and a
big D process issue because I found out
that my case was basically based on
perjury there was no due process they
were artificially creating the
case and please understand this is a
post divorce case everything was said
and done we were safe the other person
was free to do what they want wanted but
here we are pulled back in for no reason
that was evident no evidence evident it
was just repeated process that went on
for 10
years she does offer some some things on
the back page um about Solutions she
says that attorneys need to start
reporting issues and taking any and all
necessary steps to ensure that perjury
is taken seriously
it's a due process
issue this includes requesting orders
from the Family Division to refer that
perjury issue for prosecution to the
county attorney's office these are
things I tried to get done myself and
was constantly met with one thing and
that was this is the way it's
done and if you do this you might not
see your
children and that was a constant threat
I would like to um just
ask I know you had some involvement with
DCF or you tried to reach out to them
for help um so I'm sorry to stop you in
the middle of your testimony um we want
to kind of keep the testimony focused um
can you just explain how what's going on
in the divorce court relates to
DCF because if DCF had actually done
what needed to be done at that point in
time there was and they were well aware
that there was the opportunity for my
children to be removed from the country
and the state they were well aware of
the assault that already
occurred and yet it was just not enough
for them to get involved to help us so
again we wind up back in family
court with this due process perjury
issue and as I've already heard somebody
talk about it seems like it's just
accusation and you know we either accept
it or we
don't so that's why family court in my
case is a major
issue does that answer your
question representative Weber or
followup thank you so much for allowing
me this followup I'm just trying to
clarify where we are at this point yeah
yeah um so your concern specifically
with
DCF was that they
did not follow up and react in ways that
you
thought they ought to um and that they
were not as serious as they perhaps
should have been about the concerns that
you had about their kids is that a fair
statement or am I
misunderstanding because the I just want
to clarify that the thrust of this
particular um
committee is DCF and whether they are
fulfilling their duties and the family
courts is is a whole different thing and
I understand that it is part of your
story but for us the focus has to be on
the DCF portion so I just wanted to be
sure that was clear and thank you and
thank you madam chair for allowing that
so before you continue I'll go just a a
step further to clarify so the the DCF
um statutes are intertwined with the
family court statutes um but I think
that the way that certain cases are
dealt with in Family Court by those
statutes depending on the nature of them
um it it might be a different
experience so there there is overlap for
sure with the with the family court so
it's not totally out of the Wheelhouse
of this committee um but the point is
taken yes um let's relate it to and
that's where we're getting back to right
at the moment which is and to your point
thank you for the introduction on this
the reason that I mentioned the out of
state issues is that is exactly what
happened we had parental orders in place
and everything I kept telling it was
happening was going to happen I'd been
threatened with it I knew I was giving
them the
facts one of the attempts was literally
taking my two youngest kids to
France everything was in place they were
already enrolled in an American School
luckily another agency and and it was a
school system believe it or not um
intervened and that we were able to stop
the removal of the kids at that point
and get them back in the United
States the second event why I tried to
approach dcyf again saying look it's
already happened once I know this is
going to happen again I just don't know
where it happened again with one child
so the the next child was removed and
sent out of state A th000 miles away to
complete
strangers and again I could not get any
help every time I went for help it was
well you're in family court they'll
solve it if my daughter went to the
police for help you got to go to Family
Court so so no matter what agency we
went
to it was Family Court related and yet
I'm trying to get help and it was just
being pushed back into that
system so does that help clarify okay
yeah yeah and and I will add
that in the scenario when a child has
been removed it it does actually qualify
under the kidnapping law and while that
was brought up in
court they do not apply the law in court
so it was thrown out and considered
irrelevant the child did not willingly
go but the child definitely came back
and the minute she was back she was
diagnosed with severe your complex
PTSD she is now an adult and she still
is in taking care of her health and
putting that first to undo what was done
to her which could have been prevented
if we'd had the right resources in place
so the due process issues for me could
be in any
agency but a lot of it happened in
family courp because that's where we
referred to over and over and over so
what I did for you guys is an appendix a
in the first testimony
sheet I outline the the subjects of due
process that not only have I heard from
my case itself but heard from other
people and in those due process issues
that's a lot of lot of issue and that's
just 32 of them that somehow relates
back to due process and you'll see near
the bottom I really do specifically talk
about and I've heard this from other
people the removal of children from a
parent without evidence or trial and the
removal of Rights and Freedoms and
Liberties without trial then you have no
mechanism to get them back in the state
did anybody find it yes find that thank
yous here thank
you so there was no legal remedies no
matter what we did and we had to go
through this with no way out what I
didn't understand
was the makeup of the family court I did
not understand that that wasn't a judge
or that these orders were invalid or
that they were full of the liel they
were full of that I could do something
with that I had no ideas about that and
nobody in the organization was sharing
no matter how many questions I asked so
again my kids wound up being the
victims of something
horrific that had already been settled
with divorce and had already been
settled when I went into court the first
time in Family Court saying there's
nothing to be here but we went into
family court on I guess we would call it
a modification the other party decided
they weren't going to pay they weren't
going to work they weren't going to
whatever and over that period of time it
just snowballed into a decade of
horrible horrible things so the dcyf
piece for me is very valid and very real
but again I was pushed off on other
issues ending in the due process
problems is that
helpful any questions from the members
of the
Comm representative L thank you madam
chairwoman uh thank you for your
testimony uh was was there a complaint
filed with
DCF yes I the very beginning I I filed a
complaint with DCF yes okay and was a
complaint on abuse or neglect or
potential I always presented things as
potential
okay but there was evidence so there was
a trial of his assault okay uh and also
uh uh your your decree uh was he was
your X allowed to remove children from
the state I love this question so thank
you for asking it um no not without
permission um but more
importantly in the decree uh he really
didn't want them but I thought for him
to at least have them twice a
month and I almost felt like what
transpired later though I'm not going to
say it's
fact was because I wanted him to be able
to parent his kids or at least have time
with them as he got older I mean maybe
he was going through something whatever
I really fought for that and I got it
put in the
decree
so we both had the same rules set in
place if we were going to leave the
state you know we had to notify it um in
our particular case he was like you know
go anywhere you want this side of the
Mississippi go go away go you know it
was fine it was all in the decree
children and I were free to do as we
wanted so how do we end up back here in
family court with our rights being taken
away and the kids being
kidnapped it it's an issue because dcyf
could have helped us out okay
uh just one last if I may uh where was
it currently where I'm sorry what are
you still threatened current currently
where does this stand did this mine
ended in uh about about after 12 years
it ended so in
2019 we were out of Family Court
finally however we're stuck and I think
this is important for everybody to
understand because I know the victims
will understand it when I say it you're
stuck with orders of Lial
you're stuck with them and you have no
way to get rid of them and that due
process thank you represent thank you
madam chairman and thank you for being
here and sharing your testimony so I I
just want want to understand so you you
said that you put it in the decree that
he had to you know have the kids two
times had to he agreed to it eventually
okay but that that was important to you
that was important to me AB absolutely
was it before that or after that that
you told DCF that you um thought that
there could be some kind of abuse that
they needed to look at it was before and
after okay
thanks I have a question you mentioned
that the orders were not
enforceable and I understand that the
orders for um you know parenting plans
that come from dcyf petitions also come
from the same court so can you speak to
that yeah enforceability um I will start
with the fact that
enforceability for me began when I found
out I couldn't use my divorce decree as
evidence then I started saying okay but
where do I go What mechanisms do I have
no you got to go through this it's the
way it's done fine now we're getting
these rulings and you know we're opening
up the child um situation we're going to
start separating them out eventually
they were all separated out and and I
had no way to get them back together so
I kept asking the court enforce the
divorce decree enforce what we just you
know agreed upon last week and slowly
step by step by step they wound up
removing the kids
completely and here we are again stuck
No Way
Out representative Weber
so could I follow up on that when you
say they removed the kids are we talking
the court the court so did the kids go
to their father or did the kids go okay
yeah the two youngest one went went to
the father okay so basically what it was
was a complete reversal of the initial
custody order yes absolutely okay thank
you very much for clarify
that thank you any further questions
Representative no worries uh not through
this process were you proos or or did
you have sometimes I was sometimes I was
and it depended so 5050 or probably
about that yeah okay yeah I I really
tried to have as much representation as
I could but I didn't hire firms I just
hired for the moment when I needed to
okay thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony you're welcome thank you for
having
me next next to call up to speak we will
have representative JD Bernardi from
Southampton
representative welcome to the committee
use your right hand do you swear that
the testimony you're about to provide
will be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank
you may
proceed thank you madam chair and uh
committee uh I'm representative JD
Bernard
Rockingham 36 was the Southampton
Hampton Falls Kensington Newton and
plastow Southeast border of the state um
I sit on the science of tech and energy
committee as my background is
biochemistry pharmaceutical development
uh nuclear engineering Navy
submarines but I ran for office and in
doing that activity I knocked on Doors
and I always asked
people what is it that you're concerned
about with state government I may hear a
lot of stuff about the teds but every
once in a while I'm I'm GNA get that
that answer uh that relates to
activities with the state and too often
it
was the family court system
dcyf um we're dealing with Liars court
and people that aren't aren't uh
doing their job and they are hurting
people they're hurting individuals and
if you conf fix it it would be
great so uh no legislature can do that
on their own but I did sponsor last year
hr14 which turned into the special
commission looking at Family Court
basically a parallel to this
organization
what I want to commend this committee to
do and you've done it today is truly
listen to those people that are grieved
you have citizens that have been hurt
seriously hurt and they carry that pain
forward for extended periods of
time do not listen or put your faith in
presentations by agencies or judges that
talk to you for an hour an hour and a
half telling you how wonderful their
systems
are because that's what they think you
know they're
doing listen to the people that have the
problems it is only by doing that that
you are going to identify the patterns
of
activity or the problem areas with the
systems that you can then get your hands
around and potentially create solutions
to you're not going to hear the the
problems coming from the agencies you're
going to hear the problems coming from
the people it's that simple and that's
all I have to
say any questions from the
committee representative long uh thank
you madam chair I did I mean is there a
rough I I don't need to know 2,000 doors
you knocked on but out of the people you
200000 is about right yes okay and what
percentage uh would you say complained
about
DCF or Family Court well DC
speciic what percent um the rough gas
most people don't have complaints but of
of the of it was probably the most
common complaint that I had there's
there's complaints about make sure our
gun rights are maintained which and and
and then the court system those two were
the I I would say the top complaints DCF
specific uh a few yes few okay great
thank
you any further questions I have a
question um at our recent house session
on the the bill for uh it was hb1 1288
regarding due process for UNH um
students and employees and um
people being accused there uh we had a
former New Hampshire Supreme Court
Justice in our our um
resident um member of the Jud former
member of the judicial system
representative um
sorry thank you boin um give a speech
and he actually mentioned some of the
elements of due process and you uh
motioned for it to be in the journal and
I just wanted to thank you for that
because um it did give us a little bit
of insight um you know what what is your
understanding of the Essential Elements
of due
process uh thank you so uh
representative LOM former Chief Justice
uh he articulated in that speech the
minimum elements of due process for uh
an activity that was non-judicial so
here here's here's hearings or or or
proceedings in front of uh the uh uh
University tribunals or whatever about
various problems that they're they're uh
nominally
investigating um and he articulated in
that speech the very minimum elements
that one should be concerned about from
a due process standpoint if you're in
court
those elements should be even greater
but these were the minimum so I commend
you to to uh review his speech and when
you think about what element should DC
DCF be using when it is reviewing cases
it's an agency it's not a court those
same criteria ought to be your minimum
criteria you look
at thank you
no further questions thank you again for
your
testimony also signed up to speak is
Lauren vaugh of conquered New
Hampshire thank thank you if you raise
your right hand
do you swear the testimony you're about
to provide will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth thank
you may be seated and just state your
name and you
can good morning my name is Lauren vaugh
I live here in conquer and I'm going to
get super emotional so bear with me I
truly appreciate this and now I know I'm
not
alone this has
been 360 days
that I've been without my
daughter
um on March 9th I had a bad
day on March 16th my life just
stopped they barged in at 900 PM only
after doing what I was
told every
recommendation and they still took her
at 9 o'clock at night I talked to her at
10:45 that night and then not again for
five days I was an hour from
home the cpsw recommended I go to a
sober
home or some sort of
facility in their first
report they contradicted themselves very
first
paragraph I knew nothing on the way this
goes um as I stayed at the the sober
home
for longer than I attended than I
thought I would um which I'm real proud
of it was strict
and it was very eye
opening they didn't give me any
paperwork they didn't give me any
notices they didn't give me anything I
didn't talk to my
lawyer a day before the prelim um I got
to the
prelim I don't remember
it it was a
blur the adjudication was a
blur nobody defended me my lawyer didn't
defend me I was never asked I never even
spoke up until just
recently I've studied this for the past
360 days
now there is no due process in my case
there's not
one sign of due process not even them
trying until recently uh when I stood up
at the last three minutes of my hearing
I said your honor I'd like to speak if I
could and the record off the needle they
could not believe I wanted to say
something I've had it
the only one paying for this is me and
my daughter I'm the only one she's got
they dragged family that is toxic to my
mental health in to this and no
relationship with my daughter who's
seven well she just turned eight
yesterday in five years so she my family
doesn't even know this child
really and this family member is able to
take my daughter on sleepovers on the
weekends my daughter was ordered to
transition
home on November 30th because I'm in
substantial compliance with all my
orders and I have been I've been doing
exactly what is told I have not given
them any hard time dcyf my first cpsw
the one removed her she was off the case
immediately my second one I didn't hear
from her for months and now the new one
that I have thinks I am
threatening and that I
am GNA follow them to their new foster
home I don't have a car and she's very
aware of this um the reports that they
give to the court are nothing but
defamation of my character um I'm known
to many as a big crybaby as you can tell
I'm choking them back for this I have
not done
anything that has been threatening what
I've done is tell the truth what I've
done is follow the court order they took
Christmas from us it was ordered by the
judge that she would stay home she the
judge looked at my daughter and said I
want you to be home for Christmas
Eve Saturday on the 23rd of December I
got a phone call from a number I don't
know from a woman I don't know from the
division telling me that my visit was
canceled no sleepover no explanation no
nothing the foster mom that I had before
the one now we had a a working
relationship we had a business
relationship and it took a long time and
I I appreciate her very much still to
this
day we said we'll just do it by the book
we'll follow we'll just do it like this
they made up they not no cpsw was there
there was like five Cruisers and we knew
this was going to happen and I I just we
followed everything I brought all my
paperwork I showed in the court order I
did everything I was supposed to do I
never not one thing in the report that
DCF made to the court was true not a
lick of it and none of them were there
the police report I tried to obtain it
and of course I'm not going to be able
to get it within 90 days so that's out
of the question I'm still waiting for it
because I will bring it
up the fact that the judge looked at my
daughter and said you want to stay home
for
Christmas and then I told the DCF worker
the DCF worker you tell her so I put her
on speaker phone in the middle of
hanford's I said you tell her that you
took Christmas from her she didn't like
that I'm tired of letting my daughter
down they have took visits from us and
they have given not one
reason I'm exhausted and I'm not done
we're coming up on a
year I firmly believe and this isn't all
this isn't we're not cuzz you know I'm
not going to get any honesty from them
that she's with priod doters currently
when she was supposed to transition home
there's no Fosters left and
conquered I was I stayed with the Foster
system when they removed her instead of
going to family so she could stay at her
school because it would have been
normaly for her and I didn't know how
bad this was going to go they said it
was
temporary and a year later she's been
moved it's been I've had
three lawyers three cpsws three judges
the only thing she two foster homes and
the new one now they think I'm a monster
because they believe dcyf and all the
reports that they make that I'm a
monster they don't let me talk to her
and one year I have never missed a phone
call at 6 PM that phone would ring on
and she'd pick it up because the fostor
mom knew I was going to call at 6 o' I
never missed a visit never missed a
doctor's appointment never missed a
school function I have not missed and
not a
beat and now I'm a monster and I'm go
I'm I already am very well aware the
court has not been Fair there has been
no from the point of removal I have
court on the
14th
and I I pray to God every
day that this is going to go in my favor
I have a new lawyer I haven't talked
talk to
him it's all based off one thing drug
testing they drug test in a clinical
level there needs to be forensic testing
in court so if the the do is doing it
and drug court and probation then Family
Court needs to do it also DCF came to my
house on several occasions took urine
samples from me and off they went and
those were the ones that were positive
I have them all no med list no this no
that I'm not on drugs finally for once
in my life I'm sober for five years from
alcohol I'm an
alcoholic I was at the sober home
because no other facility would take me
because I'm not on drugs and I'm not
drunk they don't see that and I took
their recommendations and I did the very
I found the very hardest home I could go
to so structured it was faith-based it
was a Christian home and I still to this
day I have that Bible right behind me it
comes to every court date because the
only thing I got in this is God right
now I can't do any more than what I'm
doing I've done it all I've finished
parenting class I've done I've finished
my program which was amazing it's like
the first certificate I ever have from a
program that I was proud of and they
just they they never even they never
even mentioned it you never even
mentioned it I had a amazing letter
written by my
lak the lak at their office doesn't want
to he doesn't even want to meet with me
no more he's like I just don't want
anything to do with this case all of a
sudden he can't read drug test results
people are avoiding this case like the
plague and I and all I'm doing is
Trucking along doing what I'm told now
they can call my lawyer I'm scared of
them I just filled out my Ada request I
can't do this anymore with them the
division they violate court orders and
it's okay I would go to jail I would go
to jail they can lie to the court I
would go to jail and they get away with
they were told by the judge you are not
to go above a judge's order it was the
first thing said within five minutes of
the last hearing the very next day
that's exactly what they did the
opposite I'm tired of them and what they
get away with the due process
is it's been completely violated in many
cases but this there hasn't been any I
had to look at up after a year there's
been 14 I think uh statutes violated in
my case and I haven't even made it
through the rest of it because I can't I
can't even stomach it and I start
crying I I listen to people and I'm like
wow something needs to happen this isn't
just here this is all over the place but
I feel like here in in New Hampshire
specifically conquered where I'm in only
speaking for myself it's like taboo you
can't talk you can't talk about it you
can't do anything this is the first time
I'm saying anything about my case nobody
wants to hear it nobody wants
to I'll blast it across the media at
this point my daughter was to transition
home and she's been taken further away
she's been taken from me less visits
less parent parenting time no phone
calls I was reported by the
school the school loves me I talk to the
principal that's my
buddy what report was made oh the one
back in May for her
hygiene this is just I I I pray I pray
that this meeting something happens
because I watch these all the time on
YouTube and
and I just hope that it actually goes
somewhere and somebody hears something
because we're screaming screaming for
help at this point Thank you thank you
for your testimony and I can hear the
pain in your voice and I understand this
has been a very difficult ordeal for you
um would you be able to give us the list
of those rsas that you have found um
were
violated and if you have you don't mind
the if you don't mind the uh highlighter
yeah well that's fine and um yeah th
those are particularly helpful to have
those concrete examples of exactly where
they went off and I just have a question
did um did anybody from DCF ever um like
let you know what your rights were no
ma'am um it actually it's funny because
I get laughed at about this all the time
by many cps's cpsws so there's a trifold
brochure a pamphlet if you will um that
they're supposed to give you upon
initial
meeting well I had to print them I found
them actually my boyfriend found them
months later and uh we printed them out
and I wish they would have given me that
it explains everything explains the
process it explains everything I never
stood a shot I mean five days there's an
investigation made and I was found a
negligent
mother various locations and various
times is is what they said that's pretty
vague I mean that's in that's in one of
these uh violations of one of these
statutes also I mean as I go through and
start reading the
stuff I just it's it's I find more I had
to stop
here thank you any questions for members
of the committee representative l um
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming and sharing this with us and I'm
so sorry that you've been going through
this and your daughter was going through
this um my question is about the drug
testing so they came and they got a
urine sample from you where you live was
there any process where you could go and
give um figure out a way to do a similar
test to show at a lab or something else
where they were able to you were able to
prove that it wasn't fact the urine that
you provided or did you not have that
opportunity um I didn't know I didn't so
um because I didn't have a car I was
very open my the second cpsw I had a
great relationship with unbelievable so
when we did the home visit um she sent
somebody else I didn't know and who was
a very nice woman and we walked around
the we had a good time and I did the
drug test because we while she was there
and then I
realized that was kind of weird no like
I've never I've been in I have I've been
in court before I've been in trouble
before and I've done some drug testing
I've never seen anything like this my
sister works at a prison and we've been
kind of there is no I signed
nothing I signed nothing I actually
currently have three contracts that are
null and void with um the lab the rois
and just the foundation's counseling
which is the way act within the division
um so I'm really not bound to them right
now so I did um take five separate tests
with Quest Diagnostics and um the cpsw
never picked them up and because of
HIPPA law it states I in a court
proceeding cannot obtain my own results
so they went down the drain yeah
I and I I tried to get in touch with her
she knew I was going this was months ago
after I took the first test with um The
Division I realized that this was not I
was like that just seems weird to me
they just throw it in a bag and off it
goes like it's no ice no nothing
whatever so I said let me try Quest and
she never picked them up so I did it
again and I tried to do it smart so I
took a test with the division one day
and then I took a test with my doctor
and then I took a test I tried to get
into quests but I couldn't get in before
they
closed they all do clinical testing so
if you're on any kind of medication that
needs further testing which it'll tell
tell you right when you get your
prescription that the painting in the
neck papers that they give you read them
last page Black Box warnings I knew none
of this until now they need to do
further testing after the confirmatory
i' I'm working with samama actually um
to implement um Federal testing forensic
testing in child welfare cases because
this is absolutely the only reason I
don't have my
daughter I mean so they tested it at
like an NG which is little tiny bits
and I was like registering at
80.1 80.6 which is like a drop in an
ocean and now all of a sudden I'm back
on my meds because I'm out of the sober
home and I didn't even know they would
register at what they would what they
are but they do and it's in the
thousands now all of a sudden they're
positive and I'm like but I'm okay I
gave them all the documentation they
asked for the pharmacist my prescriber
everything blackbox warning I gave him
the prescription they don't Quest would
have done the testing the way I but it
was like
$250 could I help you follow up with me
because I think that might be something
that's in something that can be sort of
pulled out of this whole process but
sounds like a really significant issue
that we need to deal with but that might
be served better outside of this fullo
process thing but this is a significant
problem that has violated you do process
AB but it may be able to be discreet so
I'll give you my information yes ma'am
thank you on the 14 they actually uh
well DCF was told that they need to
bring in an expert if they're going to
speak on drug testing results because
they are not ladex so I'm going to
school to get my
LC any questions from the committee
representative W uh thank you madam
chair I'm a person of longtime recovery
I let the tears out all the time but if
I don't I use the Fest I'd rather let
the tears out um so you're doing all
right you're doing better than all right
all now you you mentioned the two
um two urine test positive all of them
have been positive except for one in
August and I actually had covid right
before so which is weird because I
thought definitely that was going to
come up positive for meds or something
okay and you're saying that it it wasn't
a deep enough dive into the P I know I
tested positive with uh eating OPI Opie
uh eating poppy seeds yeah and they have
to do I mean I got let go from work and
they had to pay me um to find out that I
was eating poppy seeds you know um so I
I understand where a lot of times it's a
deeper dive and that's the positive ones
you're saying that's what that was yes
all of them have been so with the due
process with this involved with like due
process in court when I
presented I gave them what they asked
for but they're not going to present it
let me I will so I did and I told the
judge I said I've asked I've asked for
further testing on samples and they
refused use and then I won't hear from
them at all like like they avoid it
until they want another test every I'm
I'm loading the ammo into the firing
squad that's pointing at me every time I
take a test with them and then they're
saying I refuse but here I am you know
at the division for Open Access like
trying to comply I picked up a contact
log the very first page said I'm a rock
star I'm killing this program the last
page says that I'm
threatening I'm frustrated because for
once I'm actually doing the right thing
in my life because it's my daughter like
my my child my only child and why
wouldn't I do everything you ask me to
do why and why would I become
threatening I become frustrated you know
I'm not being heard I'm not getting Fair
trial I'm not I'm not getting I like I
said I just spoke it's been a year for
the first time and and it's about drug
testing so I hope that on the 14th this
is mentioned like you know let's play
fair you know if this is going to be the
issue the drug testing and their own
handbook policy and procedure they're
not following they'll test me back to
back they'll test me on a Tuesday and
then they'll call me on Wednesday and
I'm like busy and they give me an hour
to get down there you know I mean it's
just frustration not threatening and yet
as you know I mean I've completed a
program I was in a sober home but they
didn't see it as that and then they did
in the next report
it's it's very hard to remain sober when
they keep telling me that I'm on
drugs he good luck on the 14th thank you
very much representative Panic um thank
you for thank you m chairman um thank
you for taking my question um I'm sorry
you're going through this horrible
ordeal I go to Quest for blood work
every three
months uh and I'm on medication and I
don't do illegal drugs and I also have
been tested positive for poppy seeds so
and I don't do drugs so I empathize with
your journey and I think that part is
very crucial on getting to the bottom of
this thank
you hearing that just look you made me
cry hearing that just it it confirms a
lot like crazy sometimes we need to be
validated yes
ma'am I have a couple of questions for
you um you had stated that DCF lied to
the court could you elaborate on that
um
there's I have everything I I didn't
know how this goes so I just
brought uh like their reviews their
reports and I brought out the orders um
you are more than welcome to to them um
the the lies the
contradictions and then the lies are are
kind
of I mean there's so many okay person so
many so are you able to maybe summarize
where they violated rsay summarize where
they I wrote them at all the top of
everything okay um just at The X parte
169 C uh 6B 169 C30 yeah we we'll take a
list
and that would be super helpful just for
us to it down this whole thing and um I
will take your question in one second
and then I just wanted to know um also
if you could give us a list of where
they um in what instances they violated
the court orders also thank you
yes you have I'm sorry and you have been
very circumspect and very careful in
what you say to us and I realize that
that's an incredibly hard um tight RPP
to walk and we appreciate you're doing
it um I was just asked to remind
everybody that this is an open case and
uh Miss Dyer maybe you can help us if if
if we take any of the stuff that you
have it has to be redacted is that
correct so you would have to make sure
that all the names
were magic Market out or something like
that is would that be the best way for
us to deal with
this
right yes and I I think for again as as
representative Leon said earlier uh this
may be something where uh um we need to
find out exactly what we can have
because everything that we take in is
public knowledge and we don't want to
let toothpaste out of the tube about
your private life or in particularly
your child's private life uh in any way
that could either reveal information
that shouldn't be revealed or get you
into some kind of trouble where what
you're trying to do is walk the line and
express your concerns which is you're
right uh so I'm I'm hoping that did you
give us contact information when you
filled in your minimal because I wasn't
sure okay um you might want to provide
that to us later on so that we could get
in touch with you uh rather than
taking information in that we shouldn't
have taken and that we don't want to
contribute to making anybody's situation
worse oh please yeah no
understandable um that's why I didn't
make copies I wasn't sure like I said I
didn't know how this goes and with it
being an open case I wasn't sure that's
why I had like you know the statutes
which is obviously um and the other
things I have like things that um I've
that have been written about me um that
never got submitted into court that you
know it's just how it's on due
process um the other thing I'd like to
bring up is that I have the the court
sum the summary the case summary and
they had eight return to send her pieces
of mail that I never changed my address
I had another case that was open that
kind of was the whole reason I got into
this case and I never got one piece of
mail from them I went to the courthouse
where she said you have some returned
mail and she gave me a stack it was all
my rights to appeal it was all my
hearing notices and then all my
orders everything up until
November and I knew I obtained all this
stuff like as time has gone on they have
never given me anything so I have never
signed anything except for my
acknowledgement of tpr if I don't comply
and uh the action safety plan in the
very beginning that's the only things
I've ever signed and the one other thing
that I is now null and
void represent Cal
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so I just wanted
to ask for clarification about the male
situation that you just described so am
I to understand that the court mailed
documents to
you those were returned as undeliverable
or rejected return refused Return to
Sender what on What basis were they
delivered are they they would typically
be marked on the I know and my
boyfriend's a letter carrier so we have
a like good relationship with with my
mealman not him but we know how the I
worked for UPS so I mean he works for
USPS so there's no reason because I
never changed my address what I did was
have a hold at the post office for my
mail the only thing I did change was DHS
because I was at the sober home and it
allowed my food stamps and stuff because
I paid for that sober home to go there
so there was no RTS on anything it was
just I never have I have don't have any
of the envelopes that would have said
any of that what I have is the stuff
that was inside of
it a follow up okay followup so when
that when those items were given to you
by the
court with the statement that these were
returned to us as undeliverable or
refused or something they were not
contained in an outer envelope no sir
they had um they had a binder that was
clipped at the top and it was just like
a two ring binder that she even had to
go get another clerk because she said
she's never seen anything like this so
and she had to sign everything out so
yeah thank you yes sir thank you
representative
quber thank you and um my question would
be um your relationship with your
attorney uh
the things like the report from the late
act or the reports from the sober home
did you provide those to your attorney
and what what happened
at that point this is attorney number
three um that I have now and he hasn't
even gone to court with me yet we've met
once we've talked three times on the
phone um the the first attorney I had he
gave nothing I gave him stuff he gave
nothing to the court
he I'll just say I don't I don't have
anything nice to say so I just have
nothing to say about that um the second
attorney she was amazing she did two he
hearings Court was in my favor things
got turned around substantial compliance
balling my eyes out of the courtroom and
hugging my kid and now that she left um
she she with through after the last
hearing and they got a new attorney
which was the attorney I was trying to
go for the minute I left the sober home
they have her now so I'm get like I was
like Wow plot twist and she's vicious
and I don't know how he's going to do it
but he seems very confident and he has a
expert witness and I just pray the 14th
is going to go well I haven't I've given
him some stuff but I guess he has a box
full of stuff I've asked for the
discovery from the division part the way
you're supposed to they won't give it to
me um the email was actually intercepted
um because I got a response back and
then it was um one of the the head field
reps emailed me back ironically so it's
telling me you know or get it from your
lawyer which they know they knew that I
didn't really have a lawyer so could I
clarify further absolutely thank you so
much so
um I got a little confused there so the
attorney that you have now is that the
attorney that has the whole box full of
information and have you made sure that
your current attorney has all of those
reports that you had yes and is aware of
those and so can get those to the court
yes so the first time we met we had a
very long meeting and uh it was we got a
lot done and I gave him everything I had
and he was pretty confident that you
know a couple of things that I gave him
he was like well I so when I it was
funny because when I walked into his
office I he said oh the drug test
results are back and I was like they've
been back they've been back twice now so
this is to be the third time different
copy same drug test three different
results so so is what you can see that
I'm trying to get at
is are you
now whatever happened in the past are
you now receiving what you feel is
effective assistance of counsel as
opposed to a councel who isn't paying
attention I hope so okay I hope so I
don't know until we get in front of the
judge at this point because I I had a
lot of trust and faith in the system
um because I've had you know I've been
through the system before and this I
don't have any faith in and you never
know this case changes on a daily basis
represent thank you thank you I just
wanted to delve into that aspect because
it's an aspect we haven't talked about
yet and it's very helpful to hear your
perspective and thank you my first
attorney I did ask him to withdraw um
several times uh we did not have a good
relationship at all and he refused he
actually told me he was doing me a favor
by not withdrawing
thank you representative kofalt for a
question um thank you madam chairwoman
um so the um I just want to see if I
understand correctly
so current opposing council is somebody
you described as a very aggressive or
effective
attorney is someone that you so so that
person is representing the division
currently yes sir okay and that is
somebody that you wanted
to hire as your attorney at one point
did you ever consult with that person
her secretary no I never made it to her
but yeah it was that was the first thing
I tried to do I'm like conflict dous
wait wait wait okay there no they were
like no sorry thank you y representative
Greg thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you for being here today and
sharing your story um and
congratulations on your sobriety thank
you I it's more not so much a question
really it might be helpful for you to
tell us like specifically where DCF um
where you felt like they didn't do what
they were supposed to however before you
do any of that back to this is an open
case and you do have an attorney now I'm
not sure that I would give us much in
writing before you consult with your
attorney because we certainly don't want
to jeopardize your case or your daughter
on something small so I would just uh
highly suggest that you speak with your
attorney before giving us anything in
writing but we do hear you
and um it's very very important so thank
you for being here and that means
everything to me really I'm going to his
office right after I leave here any
further questions from the
committee thank you very much for your
testimony and we're looking for process
issues so whatever you send us we really
don't need names I want to know where
the the issues are in the process yes
ma'am thank you got it thank
you next up to speak okay we have Andrew
noes from Bethlehem Andrew
noes n o
yees thank you sir raise your right hand
do you swear the testimony you will
provide will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth I do
thank
you you may
proceed thank you representative kushman
um find interesting that the discussion
here started about Oaths concerning
Oaths um we're hearing a lot of issues
here about uh lack of uh
truthfulness lack of oversight a lack of
accountability and uh everything I'm
about to present here concerning due
process um all
really kind of goes back to that and I
think that uh it's really important that
we remember
that DCF and the legislators that are
involved with the oversight of
DCF all swear oath to the state
constitution uh so with that due
process the Bill of Rights in article 14
and Article 15
uh Reserve back to the people the right
to remedy Swift remedy without
denial supposed to be prompt and without
delay uh again that's something that
we're not really Hearing in testimony
here and uh representative kushman thank
you for responding to the uh the will of
the people and their lawful instructions
to look into this matter um and of
course you have the you know notices and
and affidavits from the people who are
are willing to uh hold in account to
what they have seen what they see in the
lack of due process here um in Article
15 the Constitution says that no subject
shall be arrested imprisoned despoiled
or deprived of his property immunities
or privileges put out of the protection
of the law exiled or deprived of his
life liberty or estate but by the
Judgment of his peers or the law of the
land uh it's a maximum of law that no
free man shall be deprived of life
liberty or property but by the lawful
Judgment of his peers or by the law of
the land that is the common
law uh blacks law fourth definition of
the law of the land is due process of
law and so it's really interesting here
as you start to look into the founding
generation's understanding of what due
process is and how that is going to
correlate to this term law of the land
and the Constitutional view which
everybody understands here is your main
prerogative and everything else is going
to follow out of and flow out of your
constitutional
obligations that these two terms really
go hand
inand um so due process of law by law of
the land is most clearly intended that
again this is from uh Black's Law
intended the general law with hears
before it condemns which proceeds upon
inquiry and renders judgment only after
trial only after
trial a blacks law fifth definition of
common law action is an action governed
by common law rather than statutory
Equitable or civil law so I want to
pause there for a second uh there's a
lot of discussion around the statutes
which may have been
violated um concerning a parent's right
to do
process the parents rights as are
secured in the Constitution are common
law rights rights which have been
understood in Antiquity and were very
well understood amongst the founding
generation uh to exist regardless of
statutory law and in fact are secured
against uh any infringement by Statute
that's very very important here as we're
looking into the process uh into due
process and something that uh it's
imperative that you really stress that
and look
into whether any statute which may be
enacted or has been enacted already can
deprive a parent of their
rights um and and interestingly in part
two uh discussing form of form of rits
article 87 where it says all rits
issuing out out of the clerk's office
and any of the Courts of law uh Black's
Law defines court of law as in a narrow
narrower sense a court proceeding
according to the course of common law
governed by its rules and principles as
contrasted with a court of equity so
just really wanting to to nail down
here due process as it pertains to
parents their rights to their children
to be heard before they're deprived of
those rights
um is is a common law right that the
constitution secures now why am I going
back to these definitions and why am I
stressing uh
that the constitution understands the DU
the uh due process the concept of due
process in a certain way why did the
founders understand this in a certain
way
well uh often we'll hear that the uh the
standards have changed and that there's
different considerations and maybe DC
dcyf needs to be involved and certain
statutes need to be enacted because the
world has changed because we have a
different understanding of uh of the
rights of the parents and how that
pertains to the
children um and not using a historical
analysis method and uh to that I would
say that you you really need to pay
attention to what's going on in the
Supreme Court of the United States as
we're seeing a RoR a return to the
historical analysis method
so in a recent case out of
California uh justice Benitez in Fels
versus bont says quote the Supreme Court
focuses on the original understanding
and this was in a case uh pertaining to
the Second Amendment specifically
actually billy clubs in this case
but the original understanding of the
Second Amendment and thus requires
courts to give the greatest weight to
evidence from the time period of its
adoption that is because not all history
carries the same value he goes on to say
of the 39 Representatives who signed the
Constitution in
1787 none were alive 50 years later
James Madison known as the father of the
Constitution lived the longest passing
away in
1836 this is the most persuasive
evidence that the original understanding
of the second amendment protects a
person's right to keep and carry a billy
so in this case obviously they're
talking about a billy club but I I would
really stress to you the importance to
see that even the Supreme Court is
recognizing that for too long we have
used that that government agents and and
officials have used precedent as an
excuse to violate the people's
rights uh in error when the true
standard and again returning to to Due
Process the true standard must be the
historical understanding and when the
founders
wrote in our constitution the New
Hampshire constitution in the Bill of
Rights that the people should not be
deprived of their shall not be deprived
of their property of their life liberty
or state and I think we can all agree
that children are liberty interest but
by the Judgment of their peers that that
is very specific specifically meant to
be understood as these people need to go
before a jury of their peers have the
right to trial by jury and for any
accuser and anybody who's going to make
an accusation to have to swear an oath
attesting to the truthfulness of what
they say before they can be deprived of
their children and of their right to be
a
parent um you'll you'll see again in
Black's Law
that really you can summarize due
process in this statement that if any
question of fact or liability be
conclusively presumed against him this
is not due process of
law um representative kushman you're
you're uh aware of uh wer V Plymouth and
that it's ripe with references to the uh
the right of the people to a trial by
jury
and uh one of the things that are that
are stressed there in that decision is
that there is a very important
distinction between part one and part
two of our state
constitution uh part two Article 5 gives
authority to the general court uh to
make laws and uh gives it gives it power
to enact certain statutes and
such so long as quote the same be not
repugnant or contrary to this
constitution um it says that twice and
that's pretty important uh I think that
they put that there twice because the
founders really wanted us to understand
that any
discussion of Ru making um or statutory
Authority has to come underneath and
follow after the rights of the people as
is reserved to them in part
one as far as I'm aware there is no
Authority existing
anywhere to abridge the rights of the
people in part one if you can find that
granted to the general court
anywhere and especially the ability for
them to Grant something which wasn't
granted for a body like DCF to abridge
those rights I'd love to see it
um I don't think you're going to find it
though these are constitutional rights
we're talking about and
again Black's Law will inform us as to
what should be understood as a
constitutional right and that is one
that is so guaranteed as to prevent
legislative interference
therewi I don't think you need to go
much further than this if you can't
prove that there is any Authority
existing within the legislature any
bodies that it creates to take the
rights of the
people without a trial by jury
of their peers who are sworn to the to
the truthfulness of the statements that
that they're going to make um then then
you cannot take those rights and only
then can doe process
occur thank you thank you for your
testimony any questions for members of
the
committee seeing no
questions thank
you
also signed up to
speak we have actually do we need a
break gonna take a five minute break I
think Madam chair it would be very
helpful if we have some kind of time
frame because I know that I'm coming up
on deadlines not in the not too distant
future sure um we we still have a number
of people who are wishing to testify I
still have three cards um it's we you
don't need a quorum for the committee um
no I understand that so if you have to
leave that's completely understandable
on your perview I'll be here as long as
I need to to continue hearing the people
who showed up today and took the time to
testify um but I I I do understand that
need so if you need to be need to excuse
yourself we completely understand yes um
and I would just like to take a break
and I would like to caucus with the
Republicans please thank you
let's go in our
office let find another
[Music]
place no
problem
we'll just give a few minutes for the
other members to come
back
okay if it if it turns out that Mondays
aren't a good day yeah we can just talk
amongst ourselves about this um you know
we can we can go for Fridays um Fridays
much difficult for me I I have I have
things that are once a month and and
nothing's falling on the
25th the other ones are some I I have a
Commission on
Aging um one day one Monday and I have
he and overy on Friday and I might have
both Monday and Friday meetings that are
regular meetings but can
be
okay and really divvying out where are
the issues that they're talk because
we've had aoup couple that are
repeat um issues that have been
raised I think we can boil it down to
acual items
that
sure
testimony you're about to provide is the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth I do swear so help me God
thank
you so good good afternoon Madam chair
and members of the committee uh there
are some
handouts uh five in total uh for one
pagers and then uh a stapled
one uh
in
yes sorry proceed okay
uh in my case there uh have been two
different uh agencies involved uh New
Hampshire uh
DCF and also uh Los Angeles County
California
DCFS which is the analogous agency in
California so I may refer to both uh
dcyf and
DCFS uh I think uh first of all thank
you so much for taking the time to
really hear everyone here and really let
people people tell their stories and
thank you so much for emphasizing the
need for truthfulness in these
procedings I think that's extremely
valuable um what I'd like to bring to
your attention are what I consider to be
due process
violations uh in my case uh relating to
the review of reports from both new DCF
and La
DCFS uh to that
end
uh the background of this is a uh family
law case in uh with myself and the other
party involving one adult child and
three minor child
children
uh with both agencies there were cross
allegations of
abuse uh the allegations of abuse
Against Me by DCF were determined to be
unfounded the allegations of abuse uh by
the other party were uh found to be
indeterminate uh meaning there was
probable
cause uh to suspect something was going
on uh but uh not enough to uh proceed
further uh so uh essentially uh putting
in good faith but we don't have
enough uh you don't have those records
before you uh they're in the sealed
pallet
file uh I wouldn't personally have a
problem with you having them but I think
the court system would uh so let's not
do
that um the issue comes and you've heard
it earlier uh from so many people is
that these agencies are all intertwined
so uh it goes to DCF or uh DCFS and then
it goes to the court system and then the
court system has to do something with
that and in my case that's where things
uh really fell short so in by November
6th uh 2020 family court hearing uh all
of these records are coming in as
evidence we've got cross allegations
with agencies we've got uh cross
petitions to modify a parenting plan so
I would respectfully suggest this really
matters and that the
judge uh you know maybe ought to look at
those uh instead uh during that hearing
uh the judge said and uh I'm simply
quoting him who gives a
at the time we didn't know he did
that because it was a telephonic hearing
this is multi-state diversity of
citizenship uh so I'm in New Hampshire
judge is in a
courtroom uh the other parties either in
California or Michigan we actually still
aren't sure which
uh
and compounding due process from there
we then proceed to a falsification of
the court
record and if you look
here uh there's an email from escribers
dated November 12th
2020 uh concerning the court record that
says of course we are not going to
transcribe
that so we are now uh intentionally
emitting the misconduct from the
official record that seems like a pretty
serious due process
violation uh if you go to the next
uh and out here you have an email dated
November 13 2020 from chief
administrative Judge David
King uh sort of writing all about this
uh and telling uh the judicial officer
there's an issue uh so at that time he's
fully aware there's transcription issues
there's a misconduct issue you know this
is all within a week of the hearing uh I
didn't find out till almost a year later
um and after that all going on behind my
back without my knowledge there's a
misconduct
investigation uh that's dated February
16th
2021 where the judicial conduct
committee voted to dismiss this report
for the lack of any showing of judicial
misconduct with no reasonable likelihood
of a finding of judicial
misconduct again a copy to judge king
so you know November to February judge
king knows all about the falsification
of the record he knows all about the
misconduct uh I have no clue I even know
that
happened you know by the time this
letter uh the only way I found out was a
proactive Discovery request essentially
a fishing expedition to The JCC for
reports of
misconduct seems like someone maybe
should have notified
me and uh again this is all a hearing
where we're supposed to be going over
these DCF and uh
DCFS
records uh the other handout I would
draw that's the last kind of one
pager these are
double-sided uh an email from the judge
in the case who signed the orders based
on this hearing that she
knows nothing about my
case she says she suspects I was a
cosigner no recollection of you
personally no
facts um she claimed she didn't make
order substantively well what does that
mean so we kind of went through a whole
hearing on LA on DCF records and from
two different
states with a
judge who was out uh excuse me a marital
master who was out to lunch a judge who
knows nothing about the case and I kind
of suspect
nobody ever read these what's probably
most concerning to me
though is if you look at the last sort
of number five that's the only one
that's
stapled
uh the pages are in the page numbers are
in the upper right hand
corner uh it's
page 26 we don't have the whole thing a
large portion of this has been redacted
I've been unable to get a complete
copy uh so that's a discovery
issue but on page 16 and it is again
highlighted in yellow sort of the most
relevant
part uh or excuse me page 26 lines 12-
16 judge king is questioned under oath
if he told the judicial conduct
committee and he asks did I tell the
judicial conduct committee
what uh and he's asked again about what
you had found regarding the transcript
in the Au case so this comes back to the
record and he says yes so he said under
oath that he told the judicial conduct
committee about the
transcript well if he told the judicial
conduct committee about the
transcript then why did they dismiss the
complaint on February 16th
2021 so it is my belief that the chief
administrative judge again my belief
that the chief administrative judge lied
under oath in his deposition concerning
falsification of the court record in my
case and this is a very serious
matter because what was before the court
uh you know our motions to modify you
know who's doing well with the kids and
these investigations from both
agencies and as a result of that my case
has been delayed for
years I have not seen my younger
daughters
in several
years uh even though my oldest adult son
is home has lived with me for years
because he wasn't
involved and you know they sort of moved
all over the country and we
um I think nobody can track that down
and just to kind of end on something
somebody said
earlier uh there was a claim they nobody
wanted to look at their case well I
think the state wants to get rid of my
case because the
you know as you move forward we call a
three-hour supon hearing not at the
grest of either party to for the judge
to decide that New Hampshire shouldn't
have jurisdiction at all over
parenting uh when both
parties uh nobody asked for that both
parties were happy to have New Hampshire
retain jurisdiction but at the same time
uh New Hampshire gets to retain
jurisdiction over civil domestic
violence
allegations and uh I guess those are
more profitable than taking care of kids
for the state thank you thank you any
questions representative
kofalt uh thank you uh Madam chair thank
you for taking my question so one of the
handouts that you provided
was an email from Julie introcaso at
email on the back of that it is
highlighted there's a statement I
suspect I was a co-signer I believe
you referenced this briefly in your
testimony can you explain a little bit
more and sort of go into what you mean
by that statement or what you interpret
that statement to me uh a absolutely so
uh in New Hampshire our constitution
provides for judges
who take Oaths and have the ability to
issue
orders uh at the time she was
responsible for my case uh Julian tasso
was the judge signing
orders also involved in my case hearing
it was marital master Bruce dpra and
that's a marital
master and the difference is uh they're
not a judge for the
Constitution and I would refer the
committee to uh wit the justices of the
Superior Court uh from the First Circuit
Court of
Appeals uh it's a three-page decision I
can email it to you but it essentially
says that Masters have no inherent power
and derive all their Authority from the
judge uh so when she says she suspects
she was a
co-signer I think
she's trying to get out of having any
responsibility for my case when she's
the one signing orders in my
case it's how I
interpreted so it am I interpreting this
correctly then when I so she says she
has no recollection of the case you know
people I'm sure people are busy they
they cover a lot of cases but I guess
that what concerns me is that following
statement a decision that I did not make
substantively
um that's very concerning to me too I
don't know what that means okay I would
also in her uh deposit deposition dated
February 8th Julian tasso's
deposition uh she also discusses my case
under oath where she says she has no
recollection but knows that it's a
notorious case so if she's going to say
it's a notorious case how does she have
no
recollection I have a question yes
um so when
you ended up going who originally
petitioned was there a dcyf
petition um against one of you you or
your ex uh no so the brief procedural
background my case started with false
allegations of domestic violence against
me civil by the other
party uh those are often
weaponized uh and used as a silver
bullet in many cases to gain an
immediate upper hand again often
used
um those were
missed uh as soon as those were
dismissed the other party's next attempt
to essentially use agencies in the
system as a weapon with then to file
false reports with New Hampshire
DCF uh thank you yeah and when they when
you were contacted by DCF did they give
you information on what your rights were
regarding due
process
they did not uh or they excuse me they
might have let me just say I don't
recall exactly what the handout
said um I do recall telling them that uh
I would be happy to speak with them what
I wanted my attorney
present representative
Weber thank you that's very helpful and
to go a little further with the DCF
portion of the proceedings so you said
you were willing to speak with them with
your attorney present and uh was a DCF
case ever brought or were they simply
involved because of the complaint or
could you explain to us a little bit
about what happened with DCF because
that's specifically what we're looking
into okay and if I could share with just
both the agencies because they
both informative uh I understand that
but we're looking into New Hampshire DCF
so if you could right if if the other's
necessary for our understanding that's
great if you could let us know about the
proceedings with DCF that would be very
helpful so uh New Hampshire
DCF uh she made one call that was uh
completely
dismissed uh they didn't take it
seriously I mean
DCF uh the uh it then her allegations
were then reported through her therapist
as a mandated reporter so that was
enough to actually get something
open uh I believe neighbors also
reported allegations against her in that
complaint uh and so you basically have
an invest investigation opened uh
against both parties because people are
calling
them
and um well that's not enough for DCF to
take action that's certainly enough to
produce a report of who said what to
where that should be admissible in a
family court proceeding you know that a
judge uh would want to look at to kind
of help figure out what's going on in
the
case and I could say the same
essentially for L uh the Los Angeles
agency again that's initiated by the
parties but then the report should come
into
evidence and just to be completely clear
uh so there never was an although there
was a dcyf investigation because of all
of those
reports is it am I correct in thinking
that no dcyf proceeding was ever filed
in court uh yes you were correct no
proing is ever filed okay I just wanted
to be sure I understood what dcf's
involvement was thank you so
much if no one else has questions I have
a couple sure so when you
were um when DCF made contact with you
and did their part of the investigation
um concerning
you um they gave you a a brochure you
said um and did they do a home visit did
they uh interview your
kids how did that all go uh so my kids
are not with me uh in my
home uh I told them I didn't want to
speak without my attorney present my
attorney advised me to set up an
appointment with them in my home with
him present
and so uh my attorney and the social
worker and myself had a three-way
conversation at my dining room table per
the advice of my
Council thank you
and um did you feel that the report that
DCF issued
reflected um accurately what occurred at
that uh during that
conversation uh yes but I did have uh I
would consider unnecessarily delays in
Discovery getting my hands on
it uh what kind of delays how how are
you delayed just I mean if you ask the
agency with report because your attorney
wants it as evidence in a family law
case and this goes for you know
California as well then both agencies
should be providing a copy in a timely
manner and not months
later thank
you
and when so did they did the court just
refuse to consider the reports as
evidence uh I would have to go back uh
they were admitted I believe I would
have to go back and review the
transcript uh there're
certainly in the appendix in the appella
doet
uh
sealed um but I would have to I can get
the transcript to you if you
need
um if you're allowed to I I'm allowed to
it's public okay okay all right any
further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much for your time time you're
welcome also signed up to speak I have
oh a request for a sidebar with a member
I will be right
back
I
because half as much in the parking
building it's 50 cents an hour there and
a dollar an hour on street and you can
use a
credit
never
year
I apologize all right our
next person signed up to speak is Dan
baton do you swear that the testimony
you're about to provide will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help me God thank
you so my intention with today to's
testimony and the written testimony that
will follow is to use provable
fundamental truth to help paint a
picture for you to help shine some light
into the darkness of unlawful practices
that had been hidden from the people for
decades with the understanding that due
process like all law in the state must
be viewed using fundamental principles
that are not changed by time or
political
ambition before I dive in I suspect I'm
going to get some push back from people
who teach legal Theory contrary to what
I'm going to
say they might tell you that you have to
look at due process through the lens of
procedure through precedent and
statute some of them might even have the
nerve to say that the people gave up
some of their due process rights when
they formed the
state that so-called case law is in fact
the law and they may call my statements
Antiquated or
irrelevant but just as you asked us
today which I commend you for by the way
way you should demand that those people
support their claims in writing make it
clear not as Theory both
incontrovertible
fact ask them if they are willing to
support their claims on oath under
penalty of
perjury now because there are many
misconceptions about what the con
Constitution is I'm going to offer a
point of clarity from the New Hampshire
Supreme Court who said in its westerby
Plymouth
decision the division of the
Constitution into two parts was not made
without a purpose and the name of each
part is not without
significance the first is a Bill of
Rights and the second is a form of
government the second in general is a
grant of powers made by the people to
magistrates and officers of government
who are declared in part one to be the
grant tour's
agents and the first part contains a
list of Rights not surrendered by the
people when they form themselves into a
state by the reservation of these they
limit the powers granted in the second
part they Exempted themselves to the
stipulated extent from the authority of
the government they created end
quote now some people don't think of the
Constitution as the law but that's
exactly what it is it even says So
within its own
Pages part two article 101 says that the
constitution is with the law of the land
and is to be written into every law book
for
perpetuity so both in theory and in
practice the fundamental law of our
state the law that created your office
which you all promis to support in
advance of taking your seat is clear
that the legislature cannot lawfully
interfere with the rights of the people
for any reason
whatsoever now having laid that
Foundation we can move on to due process
with just two points of
clarity the founders I suggest knew that
there would be times when evil would
rear its ugly head they were not
strangers to despotic tyranical
government they were also well studied
in history and law and they understood
human
nature so they made provision in the
constitution in an effort to correct uh
to protect the body politic and its
citizens but only under very specific
conditions to allow for the taking of
Rights my following Point must not be
overlooked regarding due process and
courts there are two classifications of
Courts
courts of record and courts not of
record a court of record is the only
lawful recourse sanctioned by the
Constitution for the state to take life
liberty or property from one of the
people now the definitions of terms in
the law dictionaries and the way that
they've been taught at law schools have
been changed but the changing of the
definitions does not change the meaning
of the words at the time they were
written now scotus has recently affirmed
that statement and the Fallout of which
is Rippling throughout the court system
around in the all over the nation even
as we
speak a court of record at the time the
Constitutions were written has five
attributes that distinguish it from a
court not of record um a court of record
exercises functions independent of the
magistrate meaning the judge who who
works it is paid independently of the
agency people and Council before it it
has records and proceedings that are
open to the public so no sealed records
no closed
courtrooms it proceeds by the common law
not by
Statute and unlike courts of record
sorry unlike courts not of record courts
of record do have the power to fine or
imprison inste another way they have the
power to deprive of life liberty and
property and fifth they generally
possess a seal now legislative tribunals
on the other hand of which DCF a DCF
court is one
they do not operate independent of the
magistrate the magistrate is directed by
rules of and is paid by the agency
working in front of councel also paid by
the
agency they do not proceed by the course
of common law they proceed by
Statute their proceedings are private
their records are often sealed they're
not open to the public and legislative
tribunals by definition are not courts
of record and therefore hold no power to
fine or imprison
which means they have no authority to
deprive the people of their life liberty
or
property now I don't want you to take my
word for
this you can look for these fundamental
principles yourself and if the truth is
what you seek you will find plenty of
support for what I'm
saying one of the features of a court of
record that I want to clarify a little
bit further is that it must proed by the
common law and the reason I have to
bring this to your attention here is
because teaching about the common law is
mostly factually
incorrect people teaching you might tell
you that so-called case law has changed
or even built upon the common law or
that case precedent is itself common law
but those claims are simply not
true and are another example of
something that has been hidden from the
people the common law is precisely that
which is distinguished from from law
that is created by
legislators it is a fixed and IM able
Authority and since the Judiciary does
not make law so-call case law is a myth
at
best the common law is not some
Antiquated legal Theory nor is it
difficult to understand it is common in
that it is common to all and that it is
easy to
understand and I will provide you with a
written testimony at a later date and
I'm willing to make more statements
under oath to support my claims but if
you research this for yourself and find
it to be
true then I need to ask you does the
legislature have any Authority
whatsoever to create an agency or
tribunal to take a child from a parent
if that Tri tribunal is not open to the
public and has a magistrate who's not
independent of the
proceeding I'm sure you know my answer
to the question is that they do not and
no matter of expediency or convenience
can make it
so again I don't want you to take my
word for it look for yourself and ask
how do you know the answer to a
question the truth of the matter is
available to you if you want to find it
and as agents of the people it is your
duty to do
so Madam chair I'm just going to
apologize to my root for my rudness but
I had no idea that we were going to
proceed this long so I'm going to have
to leave and um assure people that I
will look very carefully at the tapes
going forward thank you representative
wever um thank you for your testimony um
I have a question you were saying the
definition is in Black's
Law fourth and I actually sent out that
uh definition from that um to the
members of this committee today um of
due process and and it does allude to if
I can find it to common law um that's
this one with the notes which I didn't
mean to include my comments but I was
breaking down the definition and trying
to really parse it out to figure out
what it meant and um so this is helpful
so in the definition you were talking
about common law and it's my
understanding that when it's referring
to maxims that that's referring to
that's part of the common law am I
correct in that
understanding um well point of clarity
is that I didn't I didn't bring up
Black's Law Dictionary at all I don't
believe I said that anywhere in my my
statement um but um I'm familiar with
Black's Law and I don't I don't have the
definition written in front of me so
maybe it
was Mr he um okay mentioned Black's Law
I mean look many things that I have here
are supported in Black Law sure okay so
what I'm sorry what's your question um I
was just wanted um some understanding of
what maxims are exactly um it I I know
what they are yeah um so they're
basically the law that guides law right
they're the fundamental principles that
are that underpin this legal system
would that be correct yes um they're the
foundational principles of all law
Across the Nation okay and so does
common law include it includes those and
then and case precedent though right no
no if you read uh if you read the
definition carefully case precedent is
is exactly precluded from the
definition
okay you do have to read it very
carefully it's it's a tricky sentence
and I I know that um attorneys will read
the first half of the sentence and tell
you that case precedent is part of the
common law but if you read the whole
sentence it's very clear that it is
not okay and I'm happy to provide
written testimony to support that
statement so as far as DCF and family
court goes do you know if those courts
move under that if that's how they
operate as legislative tribunals um
that's how they
operate okay they do not have a
magistrate that is independent of the
proceeding and they are often sealed
right what were the five points that I
made well I mean in D not just inside
DCF but the family court has
judges and it
has um it has rules in place to protect
due process um although we're hearing
that there might be some places where
those can be fixed so can you um can you
just help me
understand how I mean is it a problem
not only within DCF itself or is it also
an issue with how cases are handled
within the family court
that handles those I'm not here to speak
to Family Court I'm here to tell you
what due process is through the lens of
the Constitution at the time that it was
written and what a court of record is
versus what a court not of record is and
if you're going to take rights away from
people it has to be in a court of
record and the DCF court is not a court
of record that's very helpful thank you
for that clarification representative
kofalt U thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so one of
your statements uh about courts of
record was that a court of record is to
render decisions based and and I believe
that the exact quote was based on common
law not on statute or
precedent hopefully I'm close if not
spot can you can you clarify the not on
statute part because that one is a
little bit confusing to me is it common
law um supersede statute or is it not on
statute as you sort of should I take
your statement
literally
um I don't want to misspeak
um could you rephrase the question for
me um sure
so a court of record
is is to follow the Constitution and
common law I I'm with you up to that
point I also understand the what you've
presented in terms of precedent and I
will go look at that for myself to to to
understand it
better it's that you said not you know
not
on statute or
precedent I I think I'm misinterpreting
what you said because to me that sounds
like you're saying that courts of record
should not consider Statute in rendering
their decisions at all did I
misunderstand that um I'm not going to
comment only because I don't want him to
speak any further question thank you for
your testimony appreciate
it and our last witness of the day um
unless I missed anyone I only have one
card
here okay uh Betty gay The Honorable
Betty gay from
Salem thank you would you raise your
right hand do you swear the testimony
you're about to provide will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the
truth thank you thank
you my testimony today is on behalf of
Dian and Cody who three of us who are
still in the room heard uh give
testimony to a bill that directly
affected her case and she lives in
Illinois and that's why she's not here
testifying on her own
behalf her great niece adelyn jeremia
died of cute fentanyl poisoning in
November of
2020 her parents were doing drugs she
was left alone in the car with her older
sister and she ingested it and
died family members had made multiple
calls to to DCF because they were aware
that the parents were doing drugs DCF
over several months refused to intervene
so her name was already known to
them uh when she found out a few months
later when uh alen's mother who was her
niece contacted her and said I'm
pregnant she had kept it a secret and
she asked her aunt if she would take uh
take care of her two
children uh she found that so it wasn't
until I received a call in January that
she had given birth to a boy asked him
asked her if she would raise him so it
was 10 days after his birth when she was
called she responded automatically that
she would so she had uh told DC the the
mother had told DCF who she had asked
and given them her name and but DCF
never ever called
Diane
uh this their DCF policy manual 1,600
placement
considerations uh would have directed
them to try to place him with a family
member but uh she when when she
contacted now I'm trying trying to
paraphrase this and not doing a very
good job uh she the day after she
learned the baby was born Diane stated
she'd be there in 24 hours she has her
own business as a real estate person uh
she he was not out of care of his mother
at the time so she was traveling from
Illinois they asked me personal
questions about my background in
criminal history she gave them
everything so they could do a criminal
check they never responded to her she
made multiple calls to reach them and
when she finally did DCF informed her
she was not an option because she didn't
live in New Hampshire and if I relocated
to New Hampshire they would engage me in
the placement process so she did in my
opinion that's a pretty massive move and
shows great intent to take care of the
kids diyan hired in the attorney and
file for guardianship DCF informed her
that she could not file for guardianship
as they had him in their custody and
under RSA
169c guardianship was not an
option but RCA but RSA 169c defines
custody and guardianship separately
which we had to argue in court against
DCF and unfortunately the Supreme Court
gave them
the argument that guardianship can
coexist alongside dcyf
custody during the time when Diane
initially contacted dcyf and told them
she was ready willing and able to care
for him and a month before The Supreme
Court went I was living in New Hampshire
jumping through the hoops and obstacles
that DCF put in my path they were not
allowing policies I was asking for
explanations those are her words DCF
limited my visitation with my great
nephew and niece with no basis I went
through the home study process for both
children but she knew they wouldn't
place them with her because she was
already fighting with them in court for
guardianship so she asked for an appeal
of their placement decision Kasa was
involved Kasa never spoke to Diane once
during the entire process it's supposed
to be an independent party to advocate
for children but Casa didn't follow
their policies either one of which is to
get to know all family members who have
been involved in the children's lives
she gave the office of child
advocate uh to in to involve themselves
multiple times during the dcf's
retaliatory and punishing Behavior
toward me the OCA had to intervene on my
behalf more than
once we're Diane is still in litigation
and that's why I'm trying to be very
careful to follow only what she has told
me because they are still in
litigation DCF is still fighting Diane
every
chance they didn't like that I won I'll
read from her wordss I they didn't like
that I won at the Supreme Court then
then the reason we three of us heard her
testimony was because she became aware
that uh a provision was put inside a
22-page legislative bill that would
prevent anyone from obtaining
guardianship over a child in dcyf
custody fortunately she heard about it
she flew here she testified late one
afternoon and was told she had two
minutes she luckily did talk more than
two
minutes she says she has been done
confounded by the lengths and the money
DCF has spent fighting her instead of
working with her she couldn't understand
why they wouldn't want the assistance of
a non-criminal wellestablished caring
family member who their mother expressly
asked to care for her
children but then she learned more about
Child Protection Services as she got
intimately
involved because of the cloak of
invisibility
all the protective services which is an
amalgamation of many services not one
nice clean
organization because of the cloak of
invisibility they have over them the
guise of protecting the privacy of
children in abuse and neglect the law
makes it unlawful for Citizens involved
to speak out to anyone regarding details
and facts of what has occurred in their
family through the courts and dcyf
because they're threatened with fear and
jail time and not seeing the kids I'll
add
that they use it to their advantage to
block everyone from information making
it inaccessible under the cloak of
privacy she's also learned there's a
complex web of funding from federal
state and local sources leaving it
accountable to a hodgepodge of
authorities although the agencies are
usually called child protection
Services state and local agencies are
only linked by a loose set of federal
guidelines that provide broad
definitions for child ma maltreatment
along with the ACT asfa which is
adoption and safe families act it was
enacted in 1997 under the Clinton
Administration it's undergone several
rewrites but its overarching purpose has
remained steady to ensure quote timely
permanency planning for children
children but part of the emphasis on
permanency includes Financial
reimbursements for foster care
programs this starts with f Federal
Foster Care Program title 4E of Social
Security Act which functions as an
open-minded Limitless entitlement Grant
there's no limit to the amount of
funding that can be provided for
eligible foster children each year
States receive reimbursements ranging
from 50 cents to approximately 76 cents
for every dollar spent on daily child
care and
supervision administrative costs
training Recruitment and data collection
and this she took from Elizabeth breo's
Source talkover
to.org in in Diane's opinion DHHS and
DCF do not make decisions based on
what's best for the children they're
making decisions on what's best for DHHS
and the state of New Hampshire they're
incentivized to keep children in the
system and use their
programs my great mother Diane says my
great nephew had a mother who expressed
her direction for him to be in my care
days after his birth yet DCF decided to
go another route put him in the system a
system he and his sister are still in
three years
later thank you very much for the
testimony on behalf of um Miss Cody who
couldn't be here any questions from the
members of the
committee I have a question for you I
know that you've been an advocate um for
people dealing with these issues for a
while um are you aware are there any and
I'm sure we'll have the department here
at some point to to answer some
questions too are you aware of training
that goes on regarding due process
within
DCF well I'm certainly not and that's
you know that's not a statement that I
know they don't get it you certainly
could fair enough my my
concern
that it makes me very sad that money
talks so loud because if we look at how
much money the state receives from
congressional
acts that might turn people against us
because they'll say oh we'll have to
make up that many millions per
year Well my argument is if you could
get children out of the system you
wouldn't be spending that much
money um and you know it's a matter of
what's right and wrong so maybe it will
cost us more if we stop getting it but
it's just like all the people that I'm
aware of to receive who have who are
ordered to pay child support through the
state the state gets money from the
federal government for
processing child support then they turn
around and charge people paying child
support a fee for doing them this
service so they have to hire people to
process the child support and they also
then make mistakes and charge people
with being delinquent threaten them and
I know this for a fact I've heard it
directly from the people they'll send
threatening uh threats that they will be
charged uh you know for for breaking the
law for being uh delinquent and they
aren't so then the people have to go
through missing work to set the record
straight
so it's not just DCF funding it's also
child support
funding thank you any further questions
from the committee seeing none and thank
you so much for participating in this
very valuable
committee and we have one more witness
uh Victoria
peruse of Franklin New
Hampshire
thank you for being here would you raise
your right hand do you swear the
testimony you will provide is the going
to be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth yes thank
you I wanted to clarify some things in
regards to my husband's earlier
testimony there were some things that uh
were not very clear and I want to make
it known that our family is a blended
family of five children um four live
with the other party fulltime one is my
child with my husband and she lives with
us
fulltime in regards to this alleged
incident there was only a safety plan
made for four of the children where's
the concern for my
child where's the
concern if they believed that he did
this
why only four where's the safety plan
for my
child that makes no sense to
me the only other testimony I have is in
regards to the home visit that is the
only other time that I have ever had
contact with the cpsw in question she
came into our home had a walkthrough of
our home was very it stated that she was
very pleased with what she saw asked us
questions in related to discipline and
how we disciplined our
children and was very pleased to hear
our
answers and then she turned to my
husband and asked him how could you have
handled this incident
differently basically claiming my
husband guilty before even hearing him
speak
I have an email chain with her where I
provided her a link to evidence photos
videos text
messages of and a witness list of two
other adults that were
there that were not that were never
contacted she responded to this email
chain confirming that she received
the
evidence and the
email so why in the end will we finally
got our records that we
requested did she leave it out of her
report that makes no sense to me and of
course there's going to be a
preponderance of the evidence when you
omit an entire Side
Story
and that is all I have to say thank you
very much for sharing those additional
details those are also very important
any
questions I see no oh one question
representative Leon um thank you madam
chair thank you for sharing that um I
just wanted to hit on your question
about the parenting plan that simply is
that because there was any concerns with
um your your shared child or you're
looking at this as a concern about how
the the DCF is treating I am me merely
trying to look from the outside in if
there are five children that my husband
has parenting time with one living with
him full-time why are you excluding the
one child that he would have the most
access to from any safety plan if you
really believe that any allegation is
true why are you leaving a child in his
presence thank
you
all right seeing no further questions
thank you very much for your
testimony okay I don't have any more
cards
here seeing did you have something to
add right it just because can you step
up to the
microphone and state your name again and
you're still under oath yes uh Andrew
noise um just an earlier question that
you had um
representative kushman just because it
referred to one of the points that that
I made in my testimony um if if you'd
like I think that if you wanted to
restate that question and then to
representative kolt's question I think
just very very quickly that can be
addressed if if if you'd like that which
question so so you you asked about the
the the aspect of common law and how
that's going to apply to a court of
record okay um and then representative
kofalt had a question question about uh
the Court's acknowledging statute so
um yes if you have Insight on that go
ahead yep so so as as Dan referred to
the definition of common law um can be
confusing when it's defined uh by
attorneys who often have alterior
motives but it's actually pretty
distinctly defined as being um very very
different from and opposed to uh
statutory law so common law and again
I'm just reading right from blacks here
is distinguished from law created by the
enactment of
legislator and so common law is that
body of Law and you refer to the
maxims um which has been preserved in
Antiquity and what's particularly
pertinent here is that body of law and
the law common to all men that the
founders were looking at when they wrote
our
constitution um which is which is why
and and then again going to um what a
constitutional right is I referred to
that earlier in my
testimony um it's there can be no
legislative interference with a
constitutional right um I I don't know
if that answered everything to your
point that it's very helpful definitely
clarifying and then then um to represent
kof Fall's point I don't know if you
wanted to restate that question just to
make sure that I get it correctly um
thank you so yeah I was my my question
was really to the statement to ask for a
clarification of the statement that I
was hearing the statement that I was
hearing was that courts of record render
decisions or should be rendering
decisions based on the Constitution and
common law and then the
as close as I can remember not on
statute or precedent and I and I heard
the justification for the precedent part
it sounded to me like that statement was
excluding statute was it and and again
I'm asking you about somebody else's
intent when they made the
statement what is your interpretation is
do do courts of are courts of record
to exclude statute or are they to um
interpret things through the lens of
first the Constitution Second common law
and then interpret statute and render
decisions based on that right yeah so
thank you for that um it's definitely
the former um because a court of record
has to move under the common law and a
common law action is one which is
governed by the common law rather than
statutory it must only be considering
the common law and and the con
constitution in its judgments and and as
that pertains to um the question of due
process and how that's applying to
dcyf statutes are most often referred to
and utilized when taking these these
rights away and to Dan's Point earlier
if these hearings were in a court of
record in in a true common law Court of
record and uh the the matters of being
heard before a
jury of 12 of that person's peers
um and they they were not using using
statute which does not comport with the
common law right because that this came
after the Constitution was was written
and and the common law um um doctrines
and theories which were used to
establish these rights that we're
talking about here and that we're
considering as it pertains to Du process
came before and again referencing that
decision out of California there's a
pretty narrow historical window we have
to look at for what the intention was in
our constitution for a due process and
that is what we look to the maxims and
uh and common law for and as that
applies to to the Constitution so again
in short yes a true Court of record is
not going to be utilizing statute only
common law as it pertains to the rights
of the
people any further
questions seeing none thank you
again and with that we will well since
everyone's gone I guess we'll we'll push
off the uh discussion and we'll take
this uh subject matter up uh among the
the members of the committee during our
next meeting we're looking for forward
to March 25th um I also wanted to
announce the email address for the
committee um for those who wish to send
us
something sorry I had it up and now I
can't find
it all right it
is House special committee on
DCF at ledge which L eg. state. NH . us
so if you wish to submit test testimony
or additional documents you can send
them there for now until we have it
figure out that uh online submission
form and with that we'll close the he
thank
you